a quick just around guys in the room I'm
just asking have you ever slept with a
girl that said it was casual and then
she caught feelings yes yes
um ish have you ever slept with a girl
back casually and then she caught
feelings yeah dude I don't know your
name but yes yes yeah give me yes or no
yeah yeah okay
so four random guys are in this room all
saying the same what about the opposite
why do you ask me what do you mean if I
stop any kind of you know relationship
because we weren't talking about you we
were talking about the men yeah I mean
as a woman no me as a Alessandra like if
that can happen for a man you stop to
see someone because it was catching
feeling that can happen also with a man